Oh what's this the thunderhorse starting
in 12 seconds I'm gonna try this one
these are all just for fun I better
start right now five seconds I'm in and
I'm gonna be starting without pieces Oh
without pieces there goes the Queen
night there goes the Queen night and you
are gonna be seeing a lot of this stuff
a lot of this stuff coming up the
crouching the Crouching Tiger here the
Crouching Tiger position are they gonna
council Kings side come on you know you
want to cast the Kings side ooh let's
get my knight in and get my queen over
each pawn attack each pawn attack g4
here we go here we go we got meat coming
up mate
coming up the bishops hit this is
winning Oh deadly how did that happen
how did that happen there's no good
solution they're not gonna resign chop
check okay that's actually me oh I
didn't see that okay two one one
okay I have to be very cautious there's
the Queen rook goodbye to the Queen rook
goodbye to the Queen rook no Queen rook
for you no soup for you okay 83 and
we're gonna see a lot of this it's gonna
look you're gonna have nightmares of
this structure if you're watching right
now the Thunder Horse it's the Thunder
Horse open or something the Thunder
Horse and maybe I could get the same
idea the same idea coming up here we go
here we go Knight here Knight here pawn
push soon
pawn push I get the night they're down
on time Bishop here mmm no I don't wanna
trade
I don't wanna trade no you don't get any
pieces here we go g5 can I get all the
games like this an open H file open H
file let's shut that down and this night
might get excited about coming to this
square so no you don't get to play there
here we go here we go am i doing me move
this night how can I get that night out
of there
go Knight go Knight I'm gonna push in
the center now they don't have any time
well back to tournament six six two two
time and position is a ridiculous
handicap to have to work with let me
tell you what is that Queen thing she's
doing
looking for me they're looking for the
tricky scholars maid
I'm not having any of it no scholars
make for you
ecigs and then that is the end of it all
hello to white steel ik are you going to
play come on what's that what's going on
here less than 40 seconds let's go here
come on nan mover a non mover 25 seconds
let's go let's go let's go let's go 14
13 12 I'm nan mover
nobody likes a non mover nobody okay
back to tournament 12 six six six five
three okay if I get paired up against
the higher rated I'm gonna be down at
least a couple pawns I think come on
let's do this pammi up this is the
thunderhorse I'm out a horse again I'm
out a horse in the Thunder horse and we
once again have a non mover no we don't
we have a mover this is actually a mover
this is no non mover this is a mover oh
the bishop the bishop you know you want
to die bishop okay hang on I got a
little quark grip hang on let's watch
over this and let's watch over that and
resolve the tension close it up let's
come over here let's open this up close
it down close shop close shop
the nice pinned the knight is pinned
what's the queen doin
come on over here come on over here and
let's not play Knight g3 that's what I
was ready to do let's go here whoa
what's this bishop doing in my in my
territory this is my territory right
here is it he's a really my territory
let's do this
close it up
that bishop needs to get out of here
quickly get out of there
uh-oh Oh time to panic it's definitely
time to panic
oh boy oh boy okay I had to stop Queen
to d6 this is deadly diagonal oh oh okay
they didn't do that get over here
18 seconds let's go here you got to move
I got weakened squares and everything oh
no oh come over here what is my queen
doing come over here and then there
and then here Queen trade they're gonna
miss it push oh come on come on come on
come on come on come on come on ten
eleven seconds each chop chop here here
here I doing come on what is this what
is this how much time do I have do I
have enough okay they'll never suspect
that or this 20 2012 12 you just have to
throw pieces you have to just sacrifice
pieces to just burn time that's the name
of the game here name of the game is
sack your pieces so that you burn your
opponent's time
get out of there bishop okay okay Bishop
check No
here we go here we go this is maybe a
replay from the last time can we get
that at H pawn attack in I'm going for
it again here we go Bishop takes Knight
I take their Knight ah now they're gonna
be in trouble I'm getting material back
they're giving me the material back I
don't want to take that material I am
going to take that night here I can't
take there because of a fork let's get
on this diagonal now that that's been
weakened and now the knight is part the
night is pond the night is officially
pond
yeah okay let's chop that guy and then
kill the Queen can we kill the Queen
check to give a check and I don't want
to go on for that crazy and bounce so
let's not and say we did on that one
let's come over here and run with my
king 23 seconds come on sure are they
gonna go for Queen trade ah but going in
for a mate trade they got from a traded
oh they forgot about their own nookie I
take the rookie okay twenty-one Lucerne
no flank pawns for me no Bishop pawns
you will have no bishop pawns to play
this game okay let's get some space
let's chop that guy and look for me look
for a deadly mate that's the name of the
game here
here we go h7 pin that night create
weaknesses weaknesses weaknesses
weaknesses here we go everybody loves a
nice weakness and it's on h7 but I am
taking a beating the night does not have
to go anywhere or does it let's chop
this it seems like a good start you take
me I give check and then I don't know
what I want to do next okay let's do
this I think oh bishop hears no good
let's pin pin and then win pin and then
win check check and I don't have
anything okay let's give some more
checks let's burn time checks
let's give pins come on you know you
want to win this one you know you want
to win this one let's do that floor karu
ski checker ruski another check right
here maybe let's regard this
let's guard this oh if I played there I
would get four let's not and say we did
oh I got a burn time got a burn time
get over here King help out do something
come on King you know you want to not
get mated don't get me the King let's
come back here I need to check like a
maniac get the bishop how much time they
have oh I'm gonna take that Bishop let's
give a check then come here just for a
second give another check another check
over here check check right here back to
tournament no time to beat me forty two
thirty thirty twenty four
let's go let's roll
sigh Ted oh let's move those Queen side
minor pieces get those Queen side minor
pieces developed mission accomplished
okay what to do when you don't have
Queen side minor pieces you throw Queen
side pawns there you go I need my Queen
side minor pieces they did not want to
give me that and they didn't want to
give me much time either
0:09 h5 incoming problems problems my h5
the bishop has to run home scared there
he goes he's got to run home scared I
can't do this either coz Knight f6 is
gonna kill me okay
be prepared to run fast King oh they're
trying to snip that rook I know I knew
what they were up to
a4 is a correct idea open the position
up trades trade trade trade I'm on the
Queen I am on the Queen and I want to
track the Queen can I make that happen
they're um they're down on time they're
messing around too much here what are
they doing trade kill that night then I
could push here and get one of my pieces
back hopefully hopefully
and a 4 F 4 F for less than 10 seconds F
for it is chopper ruski at night check
I'll just take ok let's let's come over
here oh there goes this pond Oh what I'm
gonna take that I'm gonna go here just
premi of that they're out of time
back to tournament 56-42 36 33 less than
8 oh no more no more minor pieces for me
apparently no more minor pieces let's
watch out for that night move what to do
when you don't have Queen side minor
pieces you go with this pawn takes is
good I missed that I missed that
and oh they missed that they missed that
my queen was around to watch over that
and the Knights gonna get trapped if he
goes to be 2 and he's trapped
ok so I started out with no minor pieces
and I'm getting them back oh I'm getting
more than just that
ok so how am I actually up material
I just em just em and this rook is dead
and there's gonna be a check coming up
killer check killer check right here
queenside castle let's do that pawn
takes I get the rook uh-oh Oh get the
bishop check and then discover check a
lot of exciting things can happen let's
just do that even if it's wrong even if
it's wrong I'm gonna do it cuz of time
let's throw this in that's another check
and I could grab the rook or even just
pin it if it goes back ok looking for
this there's nothing they could do
except Queen h6 that's gonna bother me
right yep there they go and now looking
for check and then rook here or what
keep that let's just come here maybe
it's me there it is it's me back to
tournament 72 56:43 less than 16 less
than 16 here okay no Queen rook for me
no Queen rook for me huh there we go
there we go now the Jeep on the Jeep ah
they're gonna move they're coming up
with a plan here I don't want to trade I
don't want to trade come on ight nope no
trades for you I don't want to trade
although a knight takes here is
available let's watch over this Oh
Bishop takes Bishop takes that's alright
I'm gonna give up my rook I'm gonna try
to trap the clean now somehow pawn push
I'm dead I'm gonna pin okay let's get
out of this pin before it's too late and
I need to weasel my light-square bishop
around a little bit okay
let's look for me what's right what's my
kingdom what is Oh Knight f4 Knight f4
they sniffed that one out right there Oh
pawn takes pawn takes what are they
doing
oh they're beating me pawn takes pawn
push get this LightSquared bishop
rolling LightSquared diagonal come on
you know you want to get on this
diagonal right here Queen here looking
for mate tricks come on Knight f3 Knight
f3 Knight f3 OH
let's check let's check and then do what
next ah I was being tricky there pile up
on that night if it blocks what they're
gonna do they don't have any time let's
just do that
burn their time back to tournament
ninety sixty four forty seven forty
three
let's go here let's go leave one two
three four five is on my heels sort of
it's ninety sixty four fifty nine now
okay we got Billy Billy Billy Billy
Billy double O one van okay no more
minor pieces
no more minor pieces okay all right all
right clean up
where you gonna castle I want to know
more about where you're gonna castle
there you are there you are now I'm
gonna come after you looking for me
where you gonna go night come on Queen
night Bishop all bearing down here let's
come over here mate and to or something
I'm gonna take the night oh don't run
away King what are you doing oh oh there
goes my rook come on
oh no I'm in trouble the rooks gonna
come over look to eight I got to run
home with my king oh let's do this I'm
on the night oh oh
how timely how a timely King back they
get mated let's take this and take that
if they do that well that's a pretty
good move 18 seconds where's my time ah
go go go go go go go go go oh there's
got to be me here yeah no let's not
castle twelve seconds castle what is
that quick quit chasing my Queen around
what did I do to deserve that I'm
looking for Forks check let's come here
oh oh oh I can't do that either
oh man oh man I man let's do this and
then that seven seconds block a check oh
no my queen come on Bishop save the day
save the day [ __ ]
come on defense defense come on defend
defend you're not gonna get all these
pawns there's no way never suspect that
move
what a nail-biter down to the wire
110 and Oh Oh these are tough ones to
win right here these are tough get that
Bishop they'll miss it horizontal the
queen goes horizontally Oh H button the
H pine is coming after you be very
scared be very very scared of that H
Prime
it's coming after you it's coming after
you here we go here you go
Oh Oh the Queen's are coming off or are
they threatened mate
oh oh I blundered oh I blundered Oh
oh man i blundered hang on hang on I
gotta come up with something here I got
to come up with something here ah man I
don't have anything I don't have any
time either
maybe they'll miss that night right
there is brutal night right here is
brutal it's still brutal let's do this
though somehow is it good somehow there
we go come on take the bishop 24 seconds
can I somehow get this please just let
me get this maybe okay let's try let's
try for it let's try for it hang on to
come over here and then watch over stuff
oh man that's killer let's get out of
that and then this oh oh I made it
somehow I made it kill the rook can I
get this they're just gonna kill that
hang on let's come back here
oh they're ready to take my bishop they
did they went for it
run King run King run King mate it's not
me I lied oh I can't move I can't move
seven seconds oh no no no no no no no
I'm gonna mate get back over here
run give a check Oh are they gonna get
that back to tournament yes oh they ran
out of time 4.9 seconds 1:30 Billy the
Kid its Billy the Kid again here Billy
double O 1 van oh man I should not have
won that one no way no way ok does this
look familiar it should if you've been
around for any amount of time
Oh watch out for this beep iron I could
throw the beep on down to I could throw
the beep on here we go ah weakness on
the c5 and now let's shut this down I
don't want things to open up okay I'm on
both of these points now what are they
gonna do gonna chop that and maybe get
my Queen to h5 but probably back my
bishop up first let's come all the way
back let's come all the way back
Oh pawn push is good pawn push is very
good they didn't do that let's get my
queen up 85 coming up or a 4 here we go
here we go
there's Mae issues maybe if the Queen
goes too far away open this up Oh what
am i doing
let's get my LightSquared Bishop out I
should just take here they're gonna take
with their queen they're gonna miss that
oh they're down on time no they resigned
what they see they said something scared
them they saw a ghost 7 minutes 22
seconds ah let's go seven minutes um
this guy could definitely still catch me
here
1911
no no okay I've been through worse here
been through worse they don't like givin
the Queen nights do they no they don't
no no okay
close it up keep things closed here no
no no no no no I don't want any trades
no trades for you
Bishop to g7 night here and I'll
probably want to get my Bishop back to
c8 mmm not so fast not so fast has come
here in that night maybe I might want to
pin that night or actually night h6
that's better
night h6 catching up on time actually
I'm ahead on time it's a free pawn that
is what you call free pawn now I'm gonna
take that pin pin pin pin castle and
then clean up get out of this pin here
there's night there let's do this
instead keep that night on the edge and
try and trap this Bishop and if there's
a capture my dark square Bishop comes to
life I think I might be close to even
better here somehow there might be some
things that I have now starting with
this one
hitting that night and they missed it
okay a lot of lateral movement rook to
see okay let's get my knight involved
this square is going down let's give
check and then a deadly deadly deadly
for hitting everything no time left no
time back to tournament 170 140 to 127
less than six minutes okay
no Queen rook okay no Queen rook and I
can't do the Jeep on move can I know I
could let's get my bishop here before
it's too late
and right here here we go
the stage has been set for another
killer idea g5 pawn push let's I can go
with this trade I can live with that one
and then get my Bishop back over here
back over here this is where it belongs
and let's get this night involved here
we go
this 8h pawn up my queen involved and oh
they closed it down I'm gonna break it
open though I'm gonna sack that night
definitely in a sack then I actually
have the rook what am i doing and still
take care mates
there's gotta be something get my clean
out of the way and then get my Jeep on
rollin take that night if it goes to a
dark square here we go G pawn push now
open up the H file they're gonna do that
uh-oh
let's take this night I insist keep
going here I just have enough fuel I
think left to get this Oh keep going
pawns no this is leading to me isn't it
let's give a check this is a nice one
check and then this on the Queen killer
it's a killer all right check check
mm check I guess air back to tournament
no time 191 sixty-two three minutes 20
seconds
three minutes 20 seconds oh oh oh I need
to get this I need to get this here okay
I could maybe play a bit decent here boy
okay oh boy uh okay diagonal diagonal
issues diagonal issues they should kick
that night away immediately immediately
oh I'm running away scared Oh deadly
Fork deadly Fork okay alright let's work
with it run away
Queen let's come here oh oh oh oh I have
something dark square issues dark square
issues I'm not gonna take that though
they're expecting me to do that and I
don't want to I don't want to do the
things that they expect
oh that Knight is a killer he's coming
in they are having a lot of fun there
let me tell you having a lot of fun okay
oh I shouldn't have opened that up the
rooks are coming to life checks checks
let's give a check here there's got to
be something good right that pond gonna
push oh man oh oh oh
come over here save the day Queen save
the day Queen takes Knight oh who do I
have something 18 and the pin uh oh man
okay go here come
and you know you want to defend you know
you want to defend check let's come back
here yeah I'm gonna take this oh whoa
what you know it's not me
they thought it was though oh let's come
back here I got this right let's come
back let's push this pawn push it again
push it again keep pushing it
Wow did he run for a touchdown or what
that pond was fast
that was one fast pond right there back
to tournament that's the clincher I
think 45 seconds to 10 to 180 to 210 to
182 there's no catching unless that guy
gets quick resigner x' is that gonna
happen 33 seconds
33 okay if something goes wrong like
this oh I just have to let 33 seconds
come off okay there we go
and I guess I'm not gonna be looking to
win this one am I
and I still somehow win this even though
I'm down two ton of material a file oh
there it is first place I'll take it
that game was not gonna finish let me
close out of that good games Oh whew the
thunderhorse won thunderhorse